يمكن مساعده اوكرانيا بشكل افضل في هجومها
المضاد هذا السؤال طرح على طاوله اجتماع
وزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيين في اسبانيا
الذي شارك فيه نظيرهم الاوكرانيد
متروكوليبا كوليبا الذي لم يتردد في الرد
بنبره حاده على الانتقادات الموجهه للتقدم
البطيء للجيش الاوكراني في جبهات القتال
اقترح على جميع من يوجهون انتقادات ان
يصمتوا وان ياتوا الى اوكرانيا ويحاولوا
تحرير سنتيمتر مربع واحد بانفسهم الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي اطلق في شهر يونيو
الماضي لم يثبت نجاعته بالشكل الذي كان
يتوقعه جل المراقبين فالمكاسب الميدانيه
تبدو ضئيله من حيث المساحه في الظل وجود
عائق رئيسي وهو الدفاعات الروسيه الصلبه
المستنده الى الخنادق والفخاخ المضاده
للدبابات وحقول الالغام الممتده على مئات
الكيلومترات وقد خصص التحالف الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده عشرات الملي من
الدولارات لمساعده كياف عسكريا بيد ان
الشكوك بدات تحوم حول فعاليه هذا الدعم
وفقا لاستطلاع للراي اجرته شبكه
55% من الشعب الامريكي عبروا عن معارضتهم
لتقديم حزمه ماليه جديده للاوكرانيين موقف
تبناه علنا الاسبوع الماضي بعض المرشحين
لرئاسيات عام 2024 نحن نحمي انفسنا من غزو
عبر حدود دوله اخرى وهي اوكرانيا لكن
ينبغي استخدام هذه الموارد العسكريه لمنع
غزو الولايات المتحده عبر حدودنا الجنوبيه
لكن هذه الانتقادات لم تؤثر في الوقت
الحالي على جو بايدن فمنذ بدايه الحرب
انفقت واشنطن نحو 113 مليار دولار
كمساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا ستضاف اليها
مساعده جديده بقيمه 250 مليون اعلنت عنها
واشنطن يوم الثلاثاء بتجهيز الجيش
الاوكراني